once art required both effort and skill
now thanks to artificial intelligence
anyone is a potential Picasso all it
takes is a few clicks tiger
what's right but this radical new
technology poses problems for artists
like renowned wildlife photographer Tim
Flack in the case by Tiger I have to put
a lot of resources in there after Pat's
been there with the Tiger The Machine
doesn't have to do that but also the
fact that at the moment it seems that
that these images have been generated by
by scraping our images literally taken
off our website and read regenerating
something else but there's no
remuneration there trade bodies are
calling for Urgent regulation those data
sets have been a
Cube been scraped without permission so
effectively
the photographer's work that's in there
should be remunerated
the government is currently preparing an
AI code of practice but this will
initially be voluntary some artists
though see the creative potential in AI
next week Matt cullenshaw will open an
exhibition of his work with new
technology in London where photography
was invented 150 odd years ago for the
first 50 years most of the photography
that was being made was just an
imitation of painting and it took a long
time before photographers thought hey
why don't we just use this new tool as a
medium in its own right and we can go
down here and photograph up there we can
do all kinds of things the painting
can't because of its restrictions where
some see just another artistic tool
others worry about the outlines of a
deeper more troubling shift there's
never been such a a huge gap between the
sheer lack of effort or work or anything
going in and the huge sophistication
that then results coming out it's a
complete redefinition of what it is to
be creative and what art means of the AI
companies that we contacted only one
stability AI responded they said their
goal was to unlock creative potential
not replace it
just as the laptop replaced the pencil
technology is always evolving the fear
is that this time it really is different
Matthew Thompson Sky News